scp-096 the shy guy woke up in an
unfamiliar room without a thought in its
head however one thing quickly occurred
to it this was not its containment
chamber no the solid steel Cube that had
kept it locked up for decades now didn't
have a front desk or wall s covered in
strange child-like murals or tinny party
music playing over old speakers wherever
scp-096 had found itself it certainly
wasn't the place it had come to call
home if it could read it would have
registered the words behind the front
desk painted onto the wall ban bans
kindergarten where Joy Comes Alive
little did 096 know something really did
come to life here at banban's
kindergarten but it definitely wasn't
Joy
scp-096 was typically used to a much
more confined space so presented with so
much strange Freedom its natural
instinct was to wander around whimpering
quietly to itself this place was
certainly peculiar with multiple large
reinforced doors each one having a large
red button fixed to the wall above them
a strange green creature was painted on
the wall within a fixed speech bubble
that read jumbo Josh says eat fruits and
vegetables if you want to be strong like
me though 096 paid no mind to such
things this place looked like an SCP
Foundation containment facility mixed
with an off-brand Chuck E cheese and
some tiny part of the Shy Guy's dim and
dismal brain wanted to see more of it
what other Secrets could it hold the shy
guy pressed one of the big red buttons
causing the doors to open underneath it
there was a feigned sound of childish
laughter somewhere down the distant Hall
how had it ever found its way into such
a strange place the deeper the shy guy
wandered the more strange murals it saw
on the wall there was one for a large
orange cartoon jellyfish with one
staring eye where the speech bubble red
Stinger Flynn says having many arms
allows me to help a lot of people then a
squat blue gorilla-like creature with
sharp lower teeth had a speech bubble
that read Captain fiddles says
a white feminine cat-like creature has
add the speech bubble vanbelina says
kindness is free so sprinkle it
everywhere a misshapen pink bird
creature had the speech bubble opila
bird says laughter is the best medicine
so make sure to smile and of course most
importantly of all presiding over the
creativity room was a mural of a
grinning red creature wearing a pair of
party hats on its head like horns his
speech bubble read banban says sharing
is caring your pancreas is mine a
whiteboard not far from this mural had
the words run for your lives hastily
scrawled onto it to anyone but the shy
guy who had no point of reference this
was clearly not a normal kindergarten as
the shy guy passed into the hallway
slowly lumbering along it suddenly felt
an intense Spike of burning pain right
through its forehead Rising like a fever
pitch the shy guy subdued whimpers
quickly escalated into horrifying whales
of animalistic rage this could only mean
one thing somewhere something had made
the terrible mistake of gazing at the
shy guy's face in fact not 10 feet away
the unfortunate opala bird had made that
very mistake it typically peeked out
from behind one of the hallways pillars
to get a good look at any potential
Intruders or new prey wandering into its
midst but this time the beastly Birds
curiosity had taken it from Predator to
prey itself though it wouldn't realize
this until it was already too late as
the mutant bird creature skittered back
into the cavernous Hall filled with
plastic trees and an underwhelming play
area the shy guy came Galloping after it
on all fours roaring with Fury the opala
bird was shocked to see the creature
giving chase this doesn't make sense I
meant to chase you you're not meant to
chase me but things are rarely fair when
it comes to the shy guy arguably one of
the most dangerous euclid-class
creatures ever in Foundation containment
the oppola bird flapped desperately
towards the boarded-up escape hatch but
the shy guy was so much faster he
grabbed hold that the bird gripping it
in its iron clutches and began to
stretch open its bottom jaw with a blood
curdling Roar we'll spare you the
details of what happened next but
suffice to say little more than a
handful of feathers were left after
finishing off the opala bird the shy guy
reverted from Rage back to pitiful
sadness this place was no better than
the SCP Foundation there were still
creatures here to look at its face and
drive it into a state of extreme
emotional distress it was horrible the
shy guy needed to find a way to hide
himself away again so he decided to tear
away the planks covering up the escape
hatch and looked down the narrow Hall
and there the shy guy actually found
something to its liking two platforms
one on either side of the room with what
seemed to be a deep dark Chasm between
the two
for most there was an electrical lift
system for carrying them between the
platforms but the shy guy had no
interest in the platforms he only sought
the darkness below where nobody could
see his face that would suit him just
fine the shy guy jumped over the
guardrail and plummeted down below into
the dark feeling the air against its
cold gray skin as it fell felt wonderful
I dared to think that it might even find
solace in this deep dark place but as
soon as he hit something solid some kind
of metal lift system alarms went off and
flashing red lights soon made everything
down there in the darkness visible to be
exposed like this while it thought it
was hidden was the dreaded Shy Guy's
worst nightmare little did he know he
would soon become the worst nightmare of
a number of other beasts as the shy guy
crawled off the metal platform hoping
that perhaps it could find another place
to hide down here its hands and feet
splashed into shallow water had some
sprung a leak down here the shy guy
began wandering the half dark as the
water of this flooded sub-basement area
pooled around him it had no idea that
another creature was already sneaking up
behind it getting ready to strike before
096 could even react several whip-like
orange tentacles wrapped around its
Limbs and began delivering an
antagonizing shock through its body more
tentacles came in soon after wrapping
around the Shy Guy's body and face
delivering shock After Shock After Shock
with its millions of tiny venomous
Stinger barbs for a second it seemed
like the surprise attack might actually
be able to subdue the monster but little
did the shy guys attack her the
Monstrous real Stinger Flynn know that
attacking it was just another way to
activate its Infamous rage State the
second that Stinger Flynn relented even
just for a moment the shy guy grabbed
him by the tentacles and slammed him
into the watery floor again and again
and again until the grip of his
tentacles loosened around the Shy Guy's
body and he was defenseless with stinger
panicked and immobilized the shy guy
released the full force of his
Supernatural Fury striking the Demonic
jellyfish with his fists until what was
left couldn't be distinguished from the
water it used to be floating in Stinger
Flynn had been completely annihilated
the shy guy once again temporarily
returned to a state of calm and wandered
out of this watery basement into a
nearby hallway where everything was
bright and dry the walls were painted in
garish childlike drawings of a jungle
with janky looking animals the shy guy
paid no mind to any of it all he wanted
was to find somewhere that he could
actually be alone and away from prying
eyes of all these freaks this dream was
short-lived because as soon as the shy
guy found a new room a wide open
Auditorium filled with inflatable jungle
trees like a crude play area he was
being stalked yet again a powerful
muscular Predator with veins stretching
over its bulging muscles and blue skin
it knew that this Intruder had already
killed two of its fellow Garden dwellers
but this time it would put the spindly
pale Stranger in its place the Shanghai
heard something rumbling towards it from
behind and turned upon hearing the
blood-curdling war cry of ooga booga
boogauga it was the gorilla-like captain
fiddles with strands of saliva hanging
from his tusks he leaped onto the Shy
Guy and began pounding into its hideous
face with this huge blue fists Captain
fiddles would destroy the shy guy pound
him into the concrete until he stopped
moving the one thing that Captain
fiddles didn't expect was for the shy
guy to start fighting back and he was
about to learn the hard truth that the
shy guy could fight a lot harder than
him the SCP spindly but immensely
powerful arms grabbed Captain fiddles by
the shoulders and threw him into the
wall causing huge cracks to crawl up
towards the ceiling before Captain Phil
could even think about wrenching himself
free the shy guy leaped to his feet and
bounded over to him the shy guy grabbed
Captain fiddles by the ankles and ripped
him out of the wall letting his body
drop to the floor and then unleashing
hell upon Him Captain fiddles would have
begged for mercy if he wasn't already
dead before the shy guy could even begin
to calm down a trapdoor opened in the
floor beneath him dropping him into a
new area a multi-colored maze where 096
was trapped like a helpless rat with the
body count of an atomic bomb once again
the shy guy didn't need to go looking
for trouble because trouble was already
on its way the pure white cat like Ben
bellina pounced from a sharp corner in
the Maze claws barred she jumped onto
the shy guy latching onto him incline
trying to scratch his nightmare of a
face if the shy guy had ever possessed
anything resembling patience he would
have run out long before now he grabbed
vanbelina shrugging off the pain of her
laws and tossing her into the darkness
high above she flew off with a cat-like
yell and hit some distant ceiling with a
crunch suffice to say she wouldn't be
back to bother the shy guy again tired
and angry the pale Abomination didn't
feel like wandering through a maze
instead it just charged straight through
destroying a colorful wall after
colorful wall when it encountered
whatever was behind this extremely
frustrating afternoon it would destroy
it with extreme prejudice that was
almost certainty after breaking through
one more wall the shy guy tumbled out
into a strange room where a grinning red
creature was waiting for him wearing two
party hats on top of his head this was
no mere Lackey it was bamban himself the
one behind this nightmarish kindergarten
he stared right into the shy guy's face
with no fear at all almost like he knew
something that the shy guy didn't and it
was true he had no plan to fight the shy
guy himself he'd brought a champion with
him as the shy guy started to scream and
rage all the boxes behind Bam Bam
tumbled out of the way as a huge figure
Rose a behemoth at least 50 feet tall
with green skin giant teeth and huge
staring eyes it was jumbo Josh and if
the shy guy wanted to graduate from this
nightmare kindergarten it would need to
defeat him and Bam Bam the shy guy
growled digging its claws into the
ground and preparing to charge forward
challenge accepted now go check out
scp-096 look at a picture of Shy Guy In
Space the Shy Guy questions and theories
and scp-049 cures scp-096 of the
pestilence for even more SCP